you know this particular story might
finally answer the question how much
technobabble can we really crammed into
one story classic who reviewed time and
I am taking some time to work with the
fifth doctor Peter Peter Davison who I
am on record as not being a huge fan of
so you know me going through some of the
classic stories with him that I haven't
seen is a chance for me to try and get a
better opinion of the guy so today I'm
taking a look at arc of infinity the
four-part story which saw the return
spoilers if you haven't seen it okay we
saw the return of the villain Omega and
it has its ups and downs it seems to
constantly be counteracting good things
with not so good things it's a bit of a
push and pull as it goes along I suppose
I'll start with the doctor himself now
I've said in the past Peter Davison
doesn't really work for me a lot of the
time because I feel like he's detached I
don't get a real sense of genuineness
from him and oftentimes that doesn't
work for me that specific acts aspect
while still present here is working for
me a little better than he usually does
I think there's something about his
performance that when he comes across
cold and his delivery I feel like I'm
getting a glimpse of what's behind that
so that normal sense I get of you know
he's just kind of putting on an act I'm
still getting but I'm not feeling like
it's an act for the sake of an act I
feel like oh there's a little bit of
discomfort of you know nervousness I'm
you know I feel like I can see past the
act to what's actually behind it a bit
more here than I usually feel like one
of marching Davison so this is one of
the better performances from him that
I've seen in classic era so that works
pretty well
Nissa boy you know I actually kind of
like this
or at the very least I want to like
Missa the show didn't seem to like Nyssa
she just kind of hung around for a while
and she's just kind of there and that's
that's very much the case here she's not
a bad companion she's not a detriment
she's not Patrick but at the same time
she doesn't she feels like a placeholder
she feels like insert companion here it
could be anybody it almost never feels
like there's anything unique about her
that's being brought to the table which
is what you get from the best companions
now the other one we get in here is
Tegan who is a character of what the
very least has a lot more personality
than Nyssa tends to have unfortunately
this this story really goes through some
convoluted stuff to to get the plot
moving on there's a lot of staggering
coincidences Tegan showing up is the
first big one like she was gone she was
done she had bowed out from the show and
I don't know the behind the scenes you
know if she just wanted a month off for
something but I know that narrative Lee
Tegan was done traveling in the TARDIS
but now she happens to stumble across it
in a really contrived manner cuz it's
not even like the the earth location
that's tied into everything that's going
on is somewhere that she has any
business being she's from Australia this
takes place in Amsterdam but by sheer
bloody coincidence she happens to be
there at the time this is all going down
and bringing her in isn't initially part
of the villains plan either so it is
literally just coincidence that she
shows up and I just kind of bugs me but
at the same time I don't dislike Tegan I
actually kind of like Tegan my like her
attitude she's feisty as far as some of
the other stuff that's a bit up and down
Oh make it himself well I'm gonna look
don't hit me on the pronunciation I'm
American I'm gonna say oh oh make even
though they pronounce it Omega that I
have to force myself to say it like that
I'll try but I'm gonna slip up just give
me a break
I liked him a lot better in three
doctors than here and I like him in
general as a villain I like his whole
conceit I like that he has a pretty
genuine and justifiable beef with the
Time Lords and that really he just he
really just kind of wants to exist in
this universe again because he's stuck
in this antimatter universe where he
doesn't belong and there's nothing for
him there and I and you know I think I
think a villain that you can understand
where they're coming from can oftentimes
lead to some of the best villains I mean
just villains who are just nuts that can
be fun too but somebody like yeah I get
I get that that that can be really nice
to have especially in a show like Doctor
Who were a lot of the recurring villains
just kind of slot under various flavors
of crazy like Davros and the master and
so on so I did I liked him in general
and I liked him a lot in the three
doctors but as a few things wrong with
this well the first is I don't like the
redesign first off I think he was way
more iconic for lack of a better word in
in his look in his previous appearance
than he is here he just kind of it's not
even a bad head design but it's just
like I don't know where to focus I don't
know what to look at I don't know who
you know I'm just sort of looking at the
designs and going yeah okay I can't pick
a point of focus and that's kind of a
little bit distracting also the Purefoy
the same performer like for the voice I
don't think so but he comes across for
lack of a better term whinier here he
doesn't he's dumb he doesn't feel as
intimidating he doesn't feel as in
control as he did in the three doctors
so he just he isn't he's just isn't
clicking as a as a villain overall the
way he did in his last appearance they
do still do some interesting
things that I like and I kinda wish
they'd done more with the fact that when
he you know actually has a non
antimatter body briefly that he
basically stole the doctors shape you
know he looks just like him but when he
speaks he has the voice of Omega I wish
they'd done more with that I wish that
hadn't been second half of the last
episode kind of thing I kind of wish we
got more time with that because first of
all honestly Peter Davison was nicely
off-putting playing that part there's
this really weird scene that I'm not
sure I like the scene overall but this
is really weird scene where he's
wandering around Amsterdam and he's
seeing I don't even know what it is it
looks like a puppet show kinda but he's
looking down at this kid and his kids
looking up up at him and he just sort of
has this grin and it's really unsettling
it's really unnerving it's very it's
very undoctored and I really kind of
wish that Peter Davison had had more
time to work with that and to play that
part for a longer because I feel like
there there was a lot more that could
have been gotten out of that but we
don't get much that we get like maybe 10
minutes worth on that which is a shame
but I feel like that's a bit of a waste
with the Timelords
that well first of all they've got some
good actors involved they got Michael go
or gal I don't I never I never know how
to pronounce the guy's last name he was
Alfred in the 89 Batman and he's awesome
he's always awesome and he's been on
Doctor Who before he was a he was a
villain way back when but he's great and
just his voice was wonderful and he's
always a great presence I called really
early on that he was going to be the
traitor that he was gonna be the one
working with oh my god and that's not
the fault of this story it's just it's
such a cliche that when a hero is in a
situation where like uh everyone's
against me but you my old friend you
have
my back is like no that's the trailer
that's I mean that's what always happens
and that's not unique to Doctor Who
that's a general storytelling cliche
having having lord president barroso
I mean having Bruce a comeback as a
character I think was a good idea I'm
really annoyed with the fact that Bruce
has four appearances in classic whoo and
it's a different actor every time and I
know they're allowed to do that because
you can just say he regenerated every
time and in fact they do say that here
they say that flat-out but bringing the
character back when he's never the same
guy the same actor honestly it loses the
weight of even bringing him back in the
first place it's a completely new guy I
mean and I also get to a certain extent
that you know back then they weren't
really rerunning these things after they
aired and there was a decent chance that
people watching it when the new one air
didn't even see it
last time they showed up so it wasn't a
huge loss for the viewers at the time
when it was a new person but you know
for me is something I I can understand
that intellectually but that's that's
not the perspective I come at this from
I come at this from being now and being
able to watch these things you know the
ones that have been lost forever
whenever I want and from that
perspective it's annoying that it's
always a different guy I don't know what
to tell you Colin Baker that was she was
fine um and his is sort of military Time
Lord part it was well it was weird
seeing him it was extra weird because
I'm watching that performance going you
know there's nothing about that that
makes me think I bet he'd make a good
doctor of course he didn't not initially
anyway I he he is he's he's
significantly better in the audios but
yeah that's just kind of an odd thing
I'm also gonna pause and talk about
something that didn't bug me but I feel
like if I don't talk about it I
gonna get called out on it which is that
the in the resolution the doctor shoots
Omega and I feel like if I don't address
that and the fact that I'm more or less
okay with that somebody is gonna point
out that when I did my very angry rants
about hell-bent in my worst episodes
written by Steven Moffat lists that one
of the things I pointed out there was
how ticked off I was that the doctor
shot somebody he shot a Time Lord who
then regenerated
now the reason I'm okay with this and
not okay with that is basically twofold
circumstances are completely different
because here we're in arc of infinity we
are dealing with a situation where if
this guy is not killed he's going to
destroy and kill billions of people
possibly billions of worlds and he's
also gonna die no matter what so the
options are do nothing he dies and a ton
of people other than other people die or
kill him and he's the only one who dies
so first off I think the situation it's
much more warranted that the doctor did
would did and in it so I mean that so
that's the first thing because in
hell-bent that he's literally trying to
save one person he's not saving the
universe it's not for the greater good
it's for his own selfish Kim
okay I'm not getting into that but then
the other thing is just where he is in
his life there's what seven he's yeah
there's a lot of incarnations that he's
gonna go from from Peter Davison until
he's doing Peter Capaldi so I don't have
a problem with this or say Jon Pertwee
you know using his Venusian Aikido even
though I don't particularly care for
that I'm not like the doctor should
never do that like its earlier in the
guy's life I'm okay with him having
dipped into that earlier in his life by
the time we get to Capaldi the no
weapons no guns thing specifically has
been my
more rigid for a really long stretch of
time it's okay with me that there was a
point where he was more willing to bend
or break that but once he hit a point
where he kind of established that he
wasn't gonna bend or break that anymore
you kind of need to stick to it in my
mind or at least that's my feeling so
that's that's that tangent dunwood oh
the other really dumb coincidence cuz
Tegan's the like the big larger story uh
the in the moment coincidence that it
made me really roll my eyes is when
omegas minion thing the weird beaky
statue II I'm not sure what they are
thing you know tries to shoot the doctor
and the doctor just happens to bend down
and duck that just annoys me that's one
of the things that really betrays that
this was kind of going on in a period
where they really did treat this as a
kids show not a family show but a kids
show cuz that's that's a Saturday
morning cartoon save I think the other
thing I want to mention is production
design was actually pretty good on this
well and while I'm not in love with the
design of omegas helmet it looks pretty
good the his minions move a little wonky
but the design is pretty good the sets
and the props are a lot more solid and a
lot more well-designed than I am used to
seeing for this time at this time period
in doctor ooh I'm used to wobbly or sets
I'm used to you know it just looks like
something wrapped in tin foil kind of
production design and this looked better
than a lot of the color era Doctor Who
that I've seen which can really go
either way a lot of the times I think in
many ways switching to color was was
kind of rough on the show due to its
budgetary restrictions but this this is
one of the better-looking episodes I
think although the I mean the
visualization of the matrix is kind of
cheesy but it gets the job done
as far as that goes um
all the performances are pretty good I
mean even Omega isn't a bad performance
I just don't like it when I think back
to what it was I liked about him as a
villain back in the three doctors so I
think that's about it this is just kind
of a fine story for me and that's and
that's not because like it left no
impact on me it's not like it's it's
mediocre and it's just mmm
white noise throughout the whole thing
it's just that they're the things that I
like are counterbalanced by things that
are my own and or you know the things
that I like I feel like could've there
could have been more of it you could
have done more where they could have
milked that those aspects more but it
didn't so you know this is not one I'm
gonna be in a rush to to watch again
anytime soon but I am glad I saw it so
those are my thoughts on the arc of
infinity have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do support me on patreon where
you actually get to help choose what
these classic era episodes I'm going to
review our I take polls of my patrons
there's also a bunch of other stuff with
you know God Twitter and you can buy
t-shirts etc etc links for all that
stuff's down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]